[Musique]
le département de mayotte compte 3000
mineurs isolés
il s'agit d'enfants sans référent sur le
territoire contre 4 à la réunion neuf
mille naissances par an c'est la plus
grande maternité de france
deux cent soixante dix assistants
familiaux à mayotte et plus de 800 à la
réunion le champ d'action de l'enfance
et de la famille est donc encore vaste
chez nos voisins déjà dans la
coopération l'appui auprès de près de
mayotte
dernièrement notamment ils ont créé des
établissements d'accueil pour des
enfants
donc on les a aidés notamment sur les
champs juridique pour la création du
dispositif notamment et sur l'ouverture
bientôt de leur structure des cadres
maoré vienne à la réunion notamment sur
les questions de tarification des
établissements sur des questions d
agrément toutes ces données très
techniques sur lesquels vraiment nous
nous travaillons avec un appui assez
renforcée voilà pourquoi une convention
cadre a été signé par les deux
collectivités ne serait-ce que ces deux
éléments les mineurs isolés et le plus
grand nombre de naissances
ces deux jeunes préoccupation majeure à
l'ats qu'il faut consacrer des
politiques publiques
hardy et quand cela se fait en
mutualisant les moyens avec nos autres
les autres collectivités françaises 5
peut être que bénéfique et la réunion ne
peut pas s'isoler la réunion doit
s'ouvrir comme l'a toujours fait par le
passé
bien sûr démarré par ses actions dans le
domaine de l'action sociale mais on ira
beaucoup plus loin
on ira dans tout ce qui concerne les
champs de compétence dont des
départements pour justement mettre en
place des axes de coopération
mais encore une fois ce sont nos
populations qui gagnent une manière de
se rapprocher entre départements qui ne
date pas d'hier
et cela à travers la coopération
décentralisée on a besoin de parler de
l'intégration on a besoin de parler d'un
projet commun ce sont les mêmes
populations c'est les mêmes populations
de lyndiane ciani alors aujourd'hui on
aborde enfance petite enfance le médico
social
demain on apportera l'aviculture on
apportera la réflexion sur le on
apportera sur des projets d'éducation
collège est haute
cet accompagnement d'équilibrage des
dispositifs départementaux dans la zone
océan indien est un pari sur l'avenir
celui d'une france de l'océan indien
forte et unie qui pourra aussi ouvrir
d'autres perspectives
[Musique]